We got five minutes to go over
all of American history.
Wiped out the indigenous
people, oppressed the blacks,
did some good stuff
around World War II,
and now the sun is setting
on our empire.
I guess we covered it all.
No one teaches history
like I do.
That's why I let you slide
with the dress code.
You can't hide these calves
from the rest of the world.
I can't get my leg off.
-Look at these.
-You're being expelled.
So many have turned
their backs on these kids,
and I don't want to be
one of them.
We're not turning our backs
on them,
it's turning our faces
to the good students.
I am a mess inside.
Do you have any idea
how much pressure there is
on a young black man
to act like he knows
how to handle the ladies?
Michael B. Jordan
has ruined it for the rest of us.
Mario Lopez did that
for my people.
Viva Iglesias!
You clearly don't understand
what it's like
for first-generation Latina
-growing up in this country.
-I've seen Selena.
Bling-bling,
shine bright like a diamond!
I've been working to close
the gap between the haves
and the have-nots.
Have you had any luck?
I have not.
I will make this
an elite 100 school
by any means necessary.
I know that quote.
Civil rights activist
Malcolm Ten.
-What?
-Wakanda forever.
Mr. Iglesias saved the day!
We love him and his hat!